time for a little what's more likely on
this Tuesday edition of pro football
talk live the rules are very simple
there is no third category there is no
middle ground Serena Williams last week
tried to carve out a middle ground we're
doing this no it's one or the other what
is more likely to start with Antonio
Brown Chris Sims what's more likely
Antonio Brown is an issue all season or
everything is forgotten once the games
start well I mean I think if you make me
pick here I'm gonna say everything I am
making I am making you well because I
want to clarify her to qualify it but
I'm gonna say everything is forgotten
months came start I do think that once
he gets healthy and gets out there that
you know statistics yards receptions
offensive explosive plays are all gonna
be good so he's gonna be happy Gruden's
gonna be happy with its performance and
I err on that more than him being an
issue all season long but this is
Antonio Brown I mean even with what I
want to say is like forgotten once games
start I mean we're gonna have at least
one thing with Antonio Brown during the
year there's no way we go the whole year
and don't have one other thing but of
the two I think it is more likely that
everything is forgotten won't start
because I don't think Antonio Brown will
be an issue all year long because Jon
Gruden won't be able to take Antonio
Brown being an issue all year long I
mean last year the blunder was trading
away Kaleo mac but he didn't have to
deal with Kaleo mac in the building all
year this year if the mistake if the
i-told-you-so was you shouldn't have
traded for Antonio Brown there's a way
to deal with it at some point whether
it's trading him to someone else
cutting him trying to send him home with
pay like he did with Keyshawn Johnson
although technically that's that's not
permissible under the CBA although if
Antonio Brown would be fine with it it
wouldn't be any big deal so I think
between the two Gruden doesn't let it be
an issue all he can't deal with a full
season of this so yes he comes back he
plays games and everything is fine is
the more likely of those two scenarios
yeah that's even though I agree with you
there's a middle ground in there that is
probably more likely than either of
those no but I think that's a fair point
and you know you got to take in the all
accounts here that yes I mean hey we
talked about it yesterday Jon Gruden
this was his guy he stood in a table for
him you know even mike Mayock
if he didn't stand on the table for him
he's still part of this regime they're
gonna do their best to quiet any little
fires that are going on because they
wanted to be perceived that things are
you know fine and dandy and then there's
no issues so yeah I'm with you there as
far as how the how the year goes and how
to handle him in the situation next up
what's more likely Leonard fournette
says he has removed bad people from his
life Chris Simms what's more likely
Leonard fournette returns to his rookie
form or becomes the next Trent
Richardson oh I think it's returns to
his rookie form I really do I'm still a
believer in Leonard fournette his
talents I see them even last year's
underwhelming as the year was it wasn't
like Trent Richardson where I was gone
man he just doesn't look fast he doesn't
look explosive but where does his
acceleration go I didn't have those
issues watching Leonard fournette last
year that was a Jaguar team that showed
its immaturity last year he acted a fool
a few times and certainly was not
professional especially up there in
Buffalo running across the field trying
to get in a fight but this guy is a
physical freak and I think it's back to
the drawing board for the Jaguars him
and he knows money's at stake for his
future in his career I think he gets
back to his old form yeah I agree with
you and remember the Jaguars went after
his guaranteed money they tried to void
the last two seasons that's still
pending but I think that got his
attention and also the presence of Nick
Foles do you not discount that influence
will be I think Nick Foles has an innate
skill when it comes to creating the
relationships necessary with all of the
men he's going to be counting on to
block for him catch his passes and run
with the ball when he hands it to them
and he will have found a way by the time
week one rolls around in fact I believe
I don't believe because I don't know but
I would assume he already has found a
way to connect with Leonard fournette
and get him in the mindset to get the
most out of his ability I think back to
that freshman year at LSU and how great
he was right and we were all out we're
on notice here comes the next big thing
and we've been waiting for it to emerge
remember this is the guy they drafted
with Patrick row homes and deshaun
Watson both on the board this is his
year to show that he's the guy and I
think falls there is going to be one of
the big difference maker so I agree with
you it's more likely we see
we see better than the rookie forum then
the new trend
I think so too especially with Nick
Foles like you're saying you know his
first year it was better than the
statistics he'll say I think he had like
a 3.9 yards per carry average but you
know that year when they went to the AFC
championship game man I mean it was just
ground-and-pound every play up the
middle there was no respect for the pass
game by defenses but let's you know
another thing just to talk about his
talents remember that year he got
clocked you know as far as speed I can't
remember who does all that when you know
they take the speed of a player on the
field his run against the Pittsburgh
Steelers nobody got clocked at like more
faster mile per hours that's what kind
of physical freak this guy there's a
reason he was picked in top-five and
he's had some leg injuries and all that
III expect a big year from the Jags in
him all right dak Prescott sets the
quarterback market or doesn't get a new
deal this year what's more likely gosh
if I'm gonna pick out of those two I'm
gonna say that he doesn't get a new deal
this year I just can't see one him
really wanting to set the market - we're
hearing the Cowboys push back against
setting the market if they're not gonna
let's set the market with Ezekiel Elliot
who's led the NFL in rushing - to the
last three years and is the key to their
offense then you know by god they're not
gonna pay dak Prescott more money than
Russell Wilson and Aaron Rodgers and Ben
Roethlisberger I just don't see that
happening that wouldn't make sense to me
so if you make me pick one of the two I
say doesn't get a new deal this year
yeah I agree with you completely look
the bottom line is this the Cowboys are
not going to set the market with dak
Prescott his only alternative then is to
play out the season and force the
Cowboys into the franchise tag dance and
that's the other thing to keep in mind
here what is his leverage Cris his
leverage is don't sign a deal get 25
million next year 30 million the year
after that that's 55 million over two
years that he's in no position to seek
40 million per year he's in no position
to set the market so yeah it's far more
likely he just doesn't do a contract he
starts down the franchise tag path come
20 20 unless they sign into a new
contract after the season yeah
yeah and I you know I think we're all
said and done when I just if you had a
vitae read my crystal ball it's
somewhere just north of Carson Wentz I
would expect that to be the final deal
where new average money is just a hair
above him because he's been to the
playoffs twice and he's been healthy I
think that's kind of the marker I look
at well the Cowboys need to blink on one
of these deals they need to get one of
these deals done just to show people
that yes they know how to negotiate with
these players and they know how to to
craft a true win-win situation all right
last one what's more likely the
Cardinals offense leads the league in
yards or that offense gets figured out
by week a oh I got to go the they get
figured out by week eight I just I got
to see the proof in the pudding I got to
see it to believe at first I'm rooting
for Kliff Kingsbury calimary I certainly
think they're gonna have their moments
but my big question about Kliff
Kingsbury the offense the cardinals all
of that is there enough inventory of
offense do they have enough formations
and concepts and everything like that to
keep a defense honest in a I respect
college football but it just ain't the
NFL not with the 20 hour rule not with
professionals have been playing for 8 10
years all the coaching all the intricate
detailing I err on more of the get
figured out by week eight yeah I tend to
agree with you and again we picked these
categories deliberately to not let us
stray into the middle ground although I
think the middle ground in this one is
is a more likely outcome that they could
still have a very good offense that
doesn't quite get figured out but isn't
leading the league in yards I still
think they're likely to get figured out
that's gonna be the challenge you're
gonna have an advantage early on until
other defenses can see what it is
they're doing how they're using calimary
what to try to take away what to try to
force him to do that he may not like
doing and then you know then it all
starts to potentially fall apart week or
week for Mike you know that that'll play
I know exactly what you're saying is
figuring them out to me that was always
as a quarterback when I worked in New
England that's when you start to get a
picture of what teams are plus you get
three games
afford that to break down and of course
some tendency start to show team's true
DNA how they want to play all of that I
was always happy as a quarterback by
like week four when I when I was a
starter because I went oh okay alright
now we know what this defense is I know
what they like to do I realize they're
gonna have a wrinkle or two for us but
you felt comfortable what you're gonna
expect that first one first week second
week of the year man you don't know
I mean coaches are sandbagging it in the
preseason and then all of a sudden they
send out send the kitchen sink week one
and go what the hell was that so I would
expect it around that week for week five
time to see if it's the true test of
whether this is gonna be legit or are
they gonna start to get figured out very
interesting week one matchup Matt
Patricia brings the Lions to Arizona for
the calamari official NFL debut by the
way expect to see more of him on
Thursday night than we saw last Thursday
night as they get deeper into the
preseason it'll be a nationally
televised game against the Oakland
Raiders so can't wait to see what Murray
does preseason can't wait to see what he
does regularly
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports